en el último vídeo pudimos calcular la
suma de las raíces de un polinomio lo
que vamos a intentar hacer en este vídeo
es pensar en la suma de los cuadrados de
las raíces de ese polinomio entonces
digamos que empezamos con el polinomio
de segundo grado x cuadrada más a uno x
más a 2 igual a cero y ya dijimos en el
vídeo pasado porque podíamos pensar que
éste era una verdad si no fuera 1
dividimos entre ese coeficiente muy bien
entonces si tenemos este polinomio éste
tiene dos raíces digamos r1 y r2 sale y
esto también significa que podemos
reescribir el polinomio como x menos r1
por x menos r2 y esto será igual a cero
ahora bien si esto lo desarrollamos si
ya lo hicimos de hecho en el vídeo
anterior esto nos queda x cuadrada menos
r1 r2 que multiplica x
r1 r2 igual a 0 y por supuesto si no me
crees pues puedes hacerlo tú mismo
usando la multiplicación de polinomios
muy bien y en el vídeo pasado lo que
obtuvimos es lo siguiente
sabíamos bueno concluimos el vídeo
pasado que era uno más
r2 es menos a uno donde a uno es el
coeficiente del de digamos del término
de un grado menor que el más grande ok
entonces lo que queremos resolver en
este vídeo es lo siguiente a que
equivale la suma de los cuadrados de las
raíces de este polinomio muy bien
entonces para eso vamos a ver en los
siguientes vamos a ver lo siguiente algo
que se puede parecer a esta suma de
cuadrados es lo siguiente r1 y r2 si lo
elevamos al cuadrado va a incluir estos
términos verdad y esto sabemos que es
aún
al cuadrado por qué pues porque era uno
más ser perdón
r1 r2 es menos a uno si elevamos al
cuadrado de ambos lados tenemos r1 r2
elevado al cuadrado será menos a uno al
cuadrado que es lo mismo que sólo elevar
a uno al cuadrado muy bien entonces esto
si lo desarrollamos eso es un binomio al
cuadrado y esto nos queda r 1 al
cuadrado más 2 veces
r1 r2 más r 2 al cuadrado muy bien y
aquí ya tenemos justo dos los términos
que queríamos calcular verdad
esencialmente lo que tenemos es lo
siguiente digamos si si llamamos ese 1 a
esta suma entonces tendremos que que ese
1 al cuadrado déjenme ponerlo con rosa
tenemos ese 1 al cuadrado que fue justo
esto que calculamos será nuestra suma de
los cuadrados aquí tienen la suma de los
cuadrados digamos esto es la suma 2 que
es esencialmente lo que queremos
calcular y nos da ese 2
dos veces el producto de r1 r2 y tú
dirás oye pero no hemos visto quién es
bueno este de aquí si sabemos quién es
de hecho sabemos que es a 1 al cuadrado
esto es justo lo que queremos calcular
quién sería r 1 x r 2 bueno regresemos a
esta expresión que tenemos de nuestro
polinomio y aquí justamente está r1 r2
justamente aquí y que por lo tanto se
relaciona con este término quiere decir
que r1 r2 es a 2 así que tenemos que
esto es a 2 a 2 es el coeficiente que en
este caso es el que no tiene digamos el
término constante muy bien así que si
despejamos ese 2 tendremos ese 2 será
igual a ese 1 al cuadrado que es a 1 al
cuadrado
al cuadrado menos dos veces r 1 x r 2
que es a 2 menos 2 veces a dos muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos ya una forma
rápida para calcular la suma de los
cuadrados de las raíces de un polinomio
cuadrática muy bien entonces al menos
para este caso fue sencillo por ejemplo
si nos dijeran te te damos el polinomio
7x cuadrada - pi por equis más o igual a
cero entonces y te preguntan a ver
calculamos el cuadrado con perdón la
suma de los cuadrados de las raíces de
este polinomio bueno pues en vez de
calcular quiénes son las raíces es más
fácil utilizar este resultado verdad
primero recordemos que tenemos que hacer
que el polinomio tenga tenga coeficiente
1 en el de grado más grande así que
dividimos de ambos lados entre 7 y nos
queda x cuadrada menos pi sobre 7 x
más es sobre 7 es igual a 0 y ahora si
podemos calcular la verdad simplemente
tendremos que calcular a 1 al cuadrado
que es este término al cuadrado sería pi
cuadrada entre 49 muy bien ahí tienen
este término al cuadrado menos 2 veces a
dos que que en este caso es sobre 7 y
ahí está digo no se habría que
simplificar más de esto lo que sea pero
con eso basta esto fue muy bonito para
para no tener que calcular las raíces
porque aunque tenemos la fórmula de cómo
calcular estas raíces no fue necesario y
simplemente habría que calcular esta
fórmula que obtuvimos muy bien ahora
bien pensemos en esta idea tratar de
extenderla a un polinomio de grado 3
porque queremos hacer esto para que a lo
mejor después si nos da tiempo podamos
hacer un proceso de inducción y
demostrarlo para cualquier polinomio ok
entonces vamos a bajar un poco
digamos ahora que tenemos el polinomio
de tercer grado x al cubo vamos a quitar
eso x al cubo más a 1 x cuadrada más a
2x más a 3 y esto es igual a 0 muy bien
entonces esta ecuación tiene tres raíces
r1 r2 y r3 a algo que hay que aclarar es
que estos a lo mejor pueden ser algunos
de ellos iguales entre sí ahora sí tiene
tres raíces esto nos dice que el
polinomio se descompone como x-men o cr1
por equis menos r2 por equis menos r3 y
esto es igual a cero y quizás debería
regresar esto acá arriba porque lo que
sí sabemos es quién es el producto de
estos dos primeros el producto de estos
dos es lo que ya habíamos habíamos
calculado aquí es justamente esto así
que va a ser mucho más sencillo
calcularlo ya que hemos
este producto antes muy bien entonces
vamos a bajar un poquito y lo que
tenemos es lo siguiente vamos a
multiplicar estos dos perdón es este
binomio x menos r3 por este polinomio
que ya tenemos acá arriba entonces vamos
a hacerlo con mucha dedicación y con
mucha tranquilidad así que empezamos
multiplicando x por cada uno de estos
términos y lo que obtenemos es lo
siguiente
x si multiplica x cuadrada es x al cubo
x x menos r1 r2 x x será menos r1 r2 y x
x x es x cuadrada y ahora x x r1 r2 será
mas r1 r2 x vamos ahora con menos ere 3
- r 3 x x cuadrada es menos r 3 x
cuadrada
- r3 por este término se bueno los
signos menos se cancelan y nos dan más y
tendremos r3 que multiplica a r1 r2 por
equis muy bien y luego finalmente menos
con más es menos y nos queda r1 r2 r3 r1
r2 r3 así que ya podemos efectuar esta
suma y vamos a ver cómo nos queda nos
queda de este lado nos queda x al cubo
menos r1 r2 r3 que multiplica x cuadrada
y aquí no tenemos que si distribuimos
podemos poner de la siguiente forma r1
r2 que es este primero luego r1 por rtve
que es r 1 x r 3
r2 r3 de 2 x r3 que multiplica x menos
r1 r2 r3 que fue este último término muy
bien
entonces ya lo que sí sabemos y que de
hecho de aquí mismo se puede ver y que
obtuvimos también en el vídeo anterior
es que la suma de las raíces r1 r2 r3
eso ya lo sabemos de hecho es menos a 1
verdad ahora qué pasa si elevamos esto
al cuadrado muy similar a lo que hicimos
en el en el caso anterior para el
polinomio cuadrática
esto será multiplicar r1 r2 r3
multiplicarlo por el mismo así que será
multiplicar por r1 r2 + r3 muy bien ok
entonces vamos a hacerlo con mucha
paciencia r 1 x r1 nos da r 1 al
cuadrado r 1 x r 2 es r1 r2 r1 r3 es r1
r3 vamos ahora con r 2 r2 x r 1 es lo
mismo que r1 r2 r 2 x r2 es r 2 al
cuadrado y finalmente r 2 x r 3 es r2 r3
ahora con el último ere 3 por ere 1 es
r1 r3 r 3 por r 2 es lo mismo que r 2
por ere 3 y r3 sport r3 es r 3 al
cuadrado ahora sumamos sumamos y lo que
nos queda es lo siguiente ere 1 al
cuadrado más ere 2 al cuadrado más ere 3
al cuadrado eso fue sumar en esta
primera columna y ahora si nos fijamos
tenemos dos de cada uno de los productos
combinados entre r1 r2 y r3 esto es lo
mismo que dos veces dos veces r1 r2 + r1
r3 + r2 r3 y eso es muy agradable porque
esto es justo lo que queremos calcular y
esto sale de calcular la suma de las
raíces al cuadrado que también ya lo
sabemos verdad esto esto recordemos
esencialmente que es
r2 y r3 al cuadrado muy bien entonces
qué es lo que obtenemos esto de aquí es
esta parte de aquí es a1 al cuadrado muy
bien la suma de las raíces es menos a 1
pero si elevamos al cuadrado es lo mismo
que a 1 al cuadrado ahora bien quién es
esto de aquí está esta suma de los
productos digamos cruzados esencialmente
es el coeficiente que se encuentra aquí
acompañando a la equis y es esa 2 ese es
a 2 a 2 es justamente este producto
entonces esto de aquí es a 2 así que la
suma de los cuadrados de las raíces de
este polinomio se calcula de la
siguiente forma r 1 al cuadrado más r 2
al cuadrado más r 3 al cuadrado será lo
mismo
a 1 al cuadrado que ya lo tenemos de
este lado a 1 al cuadrado y ahora
pasamos este terminó restando sería
menos dos veces esta suma que es a 2 muy
bien y que coincide muy bien con la
fórmula que habíamos obtenido para el
polinomio de segundo grado entonces de
hecho se va a cumplir para todos los
polinomios esto lo puedes demostrar tú
por inducción de forma muy similar a
como hemos trabajado todo este tiempo
con inducción y no sé quizás sería bueno
dar un ejemplo por ejemplo tenemos que
tener el polinomio 10 x al cubo menos 5
x cuadrada más 7 x más 2 igual a 0 y
entonces siempre hay que recordar que
este mismo polinomio tenemos que
convertir o más bien esta misma ecuación
tenemos que convertirla a un equivalente
en donde el coeficiente de x al cubo del
el de grado más grande su coeficiente
sea 1 entonces hay que dividir entre 10
y nos queda x al cubo menos 5 entre 10
que es un medio x cuadrada más 7 sobre
10 x más 2 sobre 10 que esencialmente es
un quinto esto es igual a 0 muy bien
entonces si nosotros queremos calcular
r1 al cuadrado más r 2 al cuadrado más r
3 al cuadrado lo que tenemos que hacer
simplemente nos dice elevar a 1 al
cuadrado pero en este caso es menos un
medio así que si elevamos menos un medio
al cuadrado tendremos un cuarto verdad
menos un medio por menos un medio es un
cuarto y luego restar dos veces de a dos
que nuestro caso es 7 decimos
si te decimos entonces no sé esto esto
con todo esto es un cuarto menos 14
decimos obtenemos un denominador común
que en este caso pues puede ser
fácilmente 20 vamos a hacerlo separado
cuántos cuantos veinteavos es un cuarto
pues eso esencialmente son 5 verdad 20
entre 4 son 5 por 1 son 5 y restamos
cuántos veinteavo son 14 decimos estos
son 20 a vos pues son 20 entre 10 son 22
por 14 son 28 entonces tenemos 5 menos
28 y todo eso son 20 a vos son menos 23
sobre 20 y tú dirás oye a ver a ver a
ver cómo está eso de que la suma de unos
cuadrados me dio algo negativo como que
eso no tiene sentido
pero hay que recordar algo que las
raíces de un polinomio no necesariamente
son números reales pueden ser números
complejos y definitivamente aquí es uno
de esos casos así que espero que hayas
encontrado esto muy útil porque al menos
a mí
fascinante cómo calcular esta suma de
los cuadrados de las raíces